on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up is working on censor from
onstage assaults to mass protests over
their jokes nothing funny about being
comedian in the age of canceled culture
as won't kill comedy the last one of the
most uncensored comedians in the world
Tim Dillon
the killer interview Carl Carlson
murdered his part and child for
insurance money I've spoken to him for a
brand new crime series and tonight I'll
talk to his ex-wife and one of the
people who helped bring him to Justice
plus they're the self-style submissive
women you think A Woman's Place is
helping her husband at home so-called
Trad wise revealer 1950s so why are they
all the rage again today
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening Fernando welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored the problem is styling
yourself as the woke Prince of
impregnable Perfection is that you're
bound to eventually slip up and a lot of
people will thoroughly enjoy it when you
do take Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau the man who of course said that
the word mankind was offensive and it
should be changed to people kind is a
world-leading woke irritant famous for
virtuous even gestures like the one I
just said and last week he hosted
Ukraine's president zielinski at the
Canadian Parliament so special guests
were invited
we have here in the chamber today
Ukrainian Canadians
Ukrainian Canadian World veteran
from the second world war who fought the
Ukrainian Independence against the
Russians
and continues to support the troops
today even at his age of 98.
[Laughter]
Iranian hero a Canadian hero and we
thank him for all his service thank you
well most people with a basic education
will be aware that Ukrainian soldiers
fighting against Russia during the World
War II were Nazis yaroslov hunkers now
aged 98 served in the 14th Waffen SS
division under Nazi command I've no idea
what he did or didn't do during the war
but I do know that he was a Nazi and as
a former Nazi he probably shouldn't be
getting a standing ovation from some of
the most powerful people in the country
Hunker was invited by Canada's house
Speaker a member of Trudeau's party
who's now had to resign leaving his
leader who happens to be one of the
smuggiest men of world politics looking
more rather a smug than usual
going to be really important that all of
us push back against Russian propaganda
Russian disinformation and continue our
steadfast and unequivocal support for
Ukraine
we must push back against Russian
propaganda says the man who's just set a
lifetime supply of gift wrapped material
to Russian propagandists Russia's
disinformation machine has spun the
demented lie that Ukraine is now run by
Nazis resident zielinski of course is
Jewish making him Miss entire Fiasco
even more insulting and ridiculous it's
not the first time we've seen Trudeau
groveling
pictures infamously emerged of him in
blackface as she repeatedly he did that
which came as quite a shock to the many
people he spent all these years assuring
that he was the nicest wokiest person in
the world
I didn't understand how hurtful this is
to people who live with discrimination
every single day
I
have always acknowledged that I come
from a place of privilege but I now need
to acknowledge that that comes with a
massive blind spot
of course after that several more
pictures of Trudeau in blackface emerged
and eventually had to admit that he'd
done it so many times he couldn't even
remember how many times he'd done it
there is one thing though which Trudeau
will never apologize for
I will never apologize for standing up
for an lgdp L GT LBT
lgbtq 2 plus kids rates
oh Justin just stop man person whatever
you want to call yourself if you want to
be the most Ultra woke leader in the
world that's fine uh look I could do
that too remember the rainbow alphabet
don't wear black face
stop applauding Nazis with standing
ovations it's not that hard
well I'm joined now by the well probably
the most famous journalist in the
country today Ava Santina a tool TV
contributor Esther Krakow and the
associated to the mirror Kevin McGuire
okay
elephant in the room time Ava sent it
well but nothing else I've discovered
something today that Ava 17 is your
first name and Evans is your surname
yeah I don't know quite why we've called
you by your gloriously double barrel
first though as if that's your whole
name anyway they've been overly polite
yeah so now I've been reading all about
this journalist called uh Ava Evans I
thought who's that yeah so first of all
we're going to start calling you by a
proper name um
this has been a really difficult time
for you the last 24 hours and I was
watching all this happen in real time
last night with this GB new situation
where Lawrence Fox who I think is a
repulsive individual the best of times
decided to personally Target you in a
really horrible manner uh in a sexually
degrading Manner and he did it on Dan
wooden show uh on GB news as a result
they've both been suspended by GB news
um which is their action it's nobody
else's people are saying well you know
what about cancel cards well they've
been canceled at the moment by their own
network right so
first of all how are you no I'm good you
were one of the first big journalists to
message me last night and I really
really appreciated it um I I think you
know the support has been really really
lovely to see but you know also this
isn't really about me at all I just so
happened to be the person that they
picked on that night and he went too far
with I think I'm I was it wasn't a goal
of mine to get them suspended from the
program but look I I just think that
that that network is is out of hand and
it really needed a bit of a slap down
and I'm sorry that it's happened the way
it has but I'm glad it's happened Dan
wouldn't a presenter who's seen kind of
laughing along with it
um although he looks a little
uncomfortable actually towards the end
of it
um despite that he then tweeted you
personally expressing you know his
apologies and regret and wished he
hadn't done it and said he didn't find
it amusing and then Lawrence Fox tweeted
revealing their text exchange is showing
that Dan did appear to find it funny do
you see them until two different
categories here or accomplices to the
same problem
um I I would I would say that Dan
wouldn't facilitated it and he's an
experienced broadcaster and he should
have shut it down I also think that the
people in the gallery should have shut
it down you know they should have gone
above and beyond but look I think you
know last night Dan Wootton did try to
call me many many times and I didn't
take the phone call and I I didn't take
the phone call because I thought perhaps
the truth will come out the next day and
I'd rather not I'd rather not subject
myself to a false apology and judging by
the voicemail he left me and the truth
that has come out today it would have
been a false apology
I think we've got the clip for those who
haven't been following this it's been
gaining more traction through the day
let's look at actually what was said
we're past the world shed so I can say
this
um show me a single self-respecting man
that would like to climb into bed with
that woman ever
and she sat there and I'm going like if
I met you in a bar and that was like
sentence three chances of me just
walking away are just huge we don't need
these sort of feminist 4.0 they're
pathetic and embarrassing who'd want to
add that
Esther I can see you literally sort of
gulping in horror and what you're
watching and hearing there and it was
just incredibly offensive look I think
Fox is long ago across the the Rubicon I
remember first watching him when he was
on question time and actually I thought
he I quite supported him at the time uh
over what went down on question time
that time but ever since there's been
this descent into just trying to be as
appalling as he could possibly be and
trying to pretend well you know it's
free speech that is not what protecting
Free Speech should be about that kind of
stuff has no place on any network I mean
this this individual is mentally unwell
and I I think for me what I find the
most disappointing is the fact that Dan
didn't shut it down immediately I mean
when he said you know climb into bed
with with this person I just thought
excuse me what that's that's not your
place that's completely inappropriate
and as an experienced broadcast he
should have said actually you cannot
come on my show and say that that's how
that conversation should have gone he
shouldn't have been allowed to finish
that sentence I mean that's just
horrific
um but ultimately I think what we're
seeing here is someone who exists in an
echo chamber we talk about people being
an echo chamber Twitter and on social
media but actually there's a real
thought of being in the network chamber
in your own personal life as well and
that's something that unfortunately can
happen quite easily in this industry
especially when you wedge yourself
amongst people that have one particular
view on any issue and that's what we're
seeing manifest today he's a grown man
he has children thank God he doesn't
have daughters but at the end of the day
he should know that that's completely
inappropriate Kevin he's shown zero
remorse Lawrence Fox I mean damn what to
his credit in this has shown a lot of
remorse I say to his credit he shouldn't
have done what happened but he has at
least said it was completely wrong I
apologize and so on none of that from
Lawrence Fox he's just dug down ever
deeper and said no I absolutely stand by
everything I say yeah but peers
revolutions devour their own children
and here you've got the culture war
warriors falling out because Fox is
going to take down wooden that's what
he's done uh and it's interesting I
didn't know you'd received Ava a phone
message from him all full of Contrition
which then you know is messaging Fox to
someone else but no fox fox is violent
and it's what happens when you just get
cheered by a small segment of the
country yeah Fox can go around he can
get a crowd on Twitter or on TV but
they're the same people and you just
lose touch with reality
yeah I also think the the what happens
is people start to seek ever greater
highs they're like drug addicts yeah
right so it's kind of diminishing
returns you go down these rabbit holes
you have these wackos following you and
to feed that wacko Beast you have to say
ever more outrageous things and you just
lose all sense of decency and what he
said last night about Ava was just it
was just indecent it was just horrible
to listen to we can all agree on that
you know if this was said now on this
show there'd be outraged quite rightly I
think that a channel has a wider problem
the number of uh conspiracy theorists
and people who are quite frankly nutty
there's almost one channel during the
day and another in the in the evening
where and you know they're all on their
dodgy site shouting about the Deep state
or whatever it is
I like your new name I'm giving you uh
um
have you been on the on the flip side of
this has it been a nice experience for
you to see the huge reaction from
journalists across the divide in this
country male female I mean I've been
I've noticed it myself just the volume
of people racing to support you I'm very
appreciative of it but I'm I'm really
embarrassed by all about today I'm not
really on my phone very much and I think
you know I've never ever not wanted to
do a debate especially on this program I
will debate anything and you know
vociferously I will do it but this this
is now like about my body and about my
just my my physical being and it's just
giving me this sort of really icky
horrible feeling that I can't quite
explain yeah I get it let's move on to
something else yeah let's let's get out
of this
um let's move on actually to you know
what let's move on to this chocolate one
of my favorite subjects this is a Galaxy
bar
uh it's not as big as it used to be but
it's more expensive and Mars have now
admitted the scam they've cut the bars
and they've upped the price are we all
as outraged as I am about this it's for
our health peers it's to keep us nice
and healthy you have a smaller bit of
this nice it's basically a salad really
because it's coming from a cocoa pod so
it's a salad with a bit of your thinking
it's a salad exactly but you can't have
too much salad it's like a decadent
salad so they have to shrink it to keep
you know everything healthy and get NHS
functioning do you know they've also
done it with Weetabix so explain that
what's that about you know that's like
me striving to be healthy every morning
and now I'm getting a smaller portion of
it yes it's an old come from companies
look Mars exists to make lots of money
and here they're going to charge you
more for less it's how capitalism works
but it feels really really sneaky the
biggest chocolate story for me is that
the the dark Bounty chocolate the red
ones actually discontinued temporarily
right and I I they're my favorite thing
so my you know the lovely carry that you
all know who makes everything happen in
my world here she just had to come in
the other day looking really upset and
for all like somebody had died and I
said what's the matter who's died and
she said no it's the Bounty bars have
done I went what she said they're not
making them anymore I was like this
can't be happening so I've always a
campaign Emily matless and others have
joined in um but on a positive note
celebrations those big mixed boxes of
chocolates they stopped putting the
Bounty bars in the Milky ones and so now
because of an outraged response they've
now come up with a bounty only box of
celebrations so I think this is a start
but they're the wrong ones what we need
is a special box of the red ones you're
never happy oh yeah I don't ask so much
in life honestly I'm easily pleased
Kerry will tell you I'm easily pleased
I've never heard of anyone eating a dark
Bounty I get it all I want is I want
about three or four cups of tea when I
get here as I monitor my notes and
prepare for you special guests and so on
and then I want to have a dark red
Bounty yeah currently I can't because
they have been discontinued first world
problems
miles are watching this I need them to
understand just what this is doing to me
it's actually sending me slightly
crackers so I need I need to have that
um good to see you all Ava I'm very
sorry that you went through that thank
you I really am you had the full support
of all of us here yeah at talk TV not
just on this show I think we all you
know we hugely value your contributions
as a journalist and we'll continue to do
so thank you and uh I'm sorry you went
through it but I'm also gratified that
most right-minded people in our
profession were as outraged as I was and
you guys were and everybody else was so
we move on
good to see you on says that next has
woke killed comedy like it kills
everything else Jimmy Carr was called
painfully unfunny the weekend after he
shared a controversial jokes with new
Netflix show but one of the most
uncensored and genuinely funny
communities in the world Tim Dylan joins
me next we'll discuss this
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
attacks or protest pickets contemporary
comedians face the ever-present thread
have been canceled Jimmy Carr decided to
run that gaunt this weekend posting a
selection of his darkest jokes as tested
on American audiences they included this
one about 9 11. when Zane left one
direction for me it was like 9 11.
yeah I didn't care about that either
well the clit's gone viral for all the
wrong reasons many people pointing out
the car simply isn't very funny but many
applauded his Free Speech sentiments
including my next guest Tim Dillon who
actually is very funny so let me bring
in uh Tim Tim great to have you on the
show first of all
um thank you for having me so there's
two strands to this one is is woke
killing comedy which I want to discuss
with you but secondly the Jimmy Carr
scenario where that joke has gone viral
and people have been hammering it for it
where do you sit with that
well I I think it's funny I think it's a
funny joke I think that people have
forgotten what jokes are and they're
things that are meant to get a reaction
from people to make people laugh
involuntarily
um they're not necessarily truth they
may have elements of Truth in them but
that's not what a joke is a joke is to
say sometimes the wrong thing uh to make
people laugh you know this is about we
all have a short amount of time on the
planet and we're supposed to be able to
kind of release some of the tension of
life through humor
um so I mean Jimmy Carr is a hilarious
comedian it's a funny joke he's not
running for Senate you know if he was
running for an elected office and he
said that and people were outraged I get
it you're a comedian saying that people
are outraged that's crazy
um and I don't think woke is killing
comedy I think woke is just making it's
drawing kind of a Line in the Sand and
the people that are refusing
to censor themselves and going out there
and just saying what they want to say or
having tremendous success well you're
one of them your friend Joe Rogan's
another he's a strictly comedian like
like you are in that sense he does this
brilliant podcast but he I think fights
back against his stuff Ricky Gervais
people like that I see do it but there's
a lot also who do get genuinely canceled
I mean comedians are getting canceled
they are getting you know buried by this
sort of woke mob what's your what's your
view of that and what can they do about
it
well I think it's a part of a larger
conversation about tech and about
technology and about free speech and
about misinformation I mean I think
comedy is one part of a much larger
conversation about how do you ensure
free speech on the internet and how do
you do that in a way that allows
companies to be profitable that allows
them to you know still have advertisers
like it's a very complicated issue you
know I mean like you know my aunt says a
lot of stuff she should be kicked off
Facebook you know I mean she's crazy but
she's my aunt she's not right a comedian
she doesn't have anybody following her
right it's like you know I think what
happens to a lot of comics unfortunately
is they end up
someone that an institution wants to
make an example out of and so that if
you censor one person or you kick one
person off or one person loses their job
then the other thousands of people are
now going to censor themselves and
they're not going to wade into that
territory but I feel like it's a
conversation about tech it's not it's
not only comedians this is happening too
it's like University professors and some
of those people are affected much more
because they don't have the ability to
go perform live like we do and kind of
say what we want in a comedy club or a
theater well I mean we're all seeing
comedians getting actually attacked you
know we saw the Chris Rock Will Smith uh
Fiasco the Oscars for example Dave
Chappelle was attacked on stage in Los
Angeles there's been other examples of
this that's a pretty sinister
step forward in this canceled culture
where people I mean for Will Smith to do
what he did was was an outrageous thing
in terms of the messages sent to people
that for a joke you would physically
assault somebody and the same with Dave
Chappelle
yeah it's crazy I mean the idea that you
would physically assault somebody for
any joke is uh completely absurd you
know I mean that's just you know I I
think when you when you think of words
as violence and you think that a
statement is a violent statement then it
makes sense that people are responding
to it with violence but thankfully that
seems to be a small minority of people
uh that have done that even though
they've done it very high profile ways
these are you know Will Smith was Major
it was you know seen around the world
but most people in comedy clubs are not
doing that although it has happened but
yeah we need to get back to words are
words and violence is violence yeah I
completely agree I want to talk about
two uh sets of people who are globally
known and I've had a lot said and
written about them the first on the
lighter end uh Harry and Megan the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex you have some
quite strong views of my favorites yeah
tell me tell me about your views of
these two I love them they're my are my
favorites you know reality television in
America had kind of died down and
they've brought it back
um it's very interesting to make a
three-part documentary on Netflix about
how bad things are while living in a
castle I find that the lack of
self-awareness there to be very fun I
mean they're very funny they simulated
some type of car chase in New York City
that didn't really happen uh it was a
cab driver that was driving them around
said it did not happen
um they've you know I know people in Los
Angeles that they've texted and reached
out to because they kind of want to hang
out in these circles with celebrities
they got a big deal at Spotify spot if I
didn't make any money now the articles
are coming out that Spotify lost a lot
of money giving them money to do all
these things that they never ended up
really doing and nobody ended up
listening after the first few episodes
um so victimhood it makes me laugh and
when someone is clearly not a victim and
I think living in a castle being part of
a royal family
um would make you not a victim and to me
to portray yourself as somebody who's
having a rough go of it whilst living in
a castle with royal protection and then
leaving and flying to America to stay in
the home of a big celebrity and it's a
beautiful home they make me laugh I mean
I I like them I hope they don't go away
I hope they keep doing this I hope they
keep behaving shamefully it's great for
the tabloids it's great for us we keep
doing it keep simulating car chases
simulate terrorist attacks whatever they
want to do that keeps them in the news
I'm all for it
all you is amused by your country's
political situation right now because
many people outside of America are
looking at the prospect of Joe Biden who
can barely string a sentence together
all stand on his feet yeah coming up
against a guy in Donald Trump who's now
had nearly a hundred criminal charges
leveled against him the idea this is the
best America can do is ridiculous and
laughable but do you find it as funny
I find it funny it's it's it's clearly
disturbing because we're at the end of a
of an Empire and that's quite obvious to
everyone who's watching I mean children
who are paying attention to this can see
there's a problem
um but it is funny I mean you know the
other day Joe Biden walked off uh stage
and finished giving his speech and they
just started playing like jazz music and
he wandered off the stage to Jazz and it
was like the most poetic moment of like
the sun setting on the Empire like it's
finally over this guy's just kind of
wandering off the stage to like jazz
piano as it ends yeah no it's um it's
disturbing but it's also you know you
gotta you gotta enjoy your life and
these are things you don't have a lot of
control over so you you really have to
just kind of laugh
it is funny you can't get away from it
um the Tim Dylan show hugely popular 568
000 subscribers uh congratulations on
that you have more sir you want more we
all want more I'm not gonna boast I've
got one and a half million I don't want
to tell you I've got one and a half
million subscribers I don't want to make
you feel jealous
yeah
uh on a series though it's great to have
you on the show please come back uh
you're a very funny guy and we
appreciate it thank you thank you so
much peers I'd love to see you in London
thank you buddy well I'd love that take
care on session next I'm joined by
Esther Williams the self-style Trad
white who spends hours cooking and
cleaning while her husband goes to work
she's amassed hundreds of thousands of
followers are promoting this 1950s Trend
that isn't an example that all women
should follow that debate next
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think there's only one for one king
these mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean their
American folk do you believe you can win
this war it's making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy letby will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board should
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
let it roll
[Music]
stop producing oil the knock-on effect
is far larger than just CO2 I nearly
have empathy when I'm speaking to them I
know I know you're probably going to
vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American ass thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drunk you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
this is talk TV
foreign
[Music]
controversy originally by claiming that
getting divorced before 30 is chic
so it seems that a lot of ladies are
getting divorced
before they turn dirty and as someone
who got married at 26 has been separated
for a little over a year
32. I don't think there's anything
better if there is nothing better than
being in your 30s still being hot maybe
having a little bit of your own money
figuring out what you want to do with
your life for all of those people who
are stressed or feeling stressed about
that about being divorced like it's a
it's it's good congratulations
it's like congratulations
she's ridiculous uh well divorce is
certainly becoming more common a
marriage itself is becoming a fierce
Frontier in the Raging culturals on one
side there are feminist rejecting a
deity concept
on the other so-called Trad wives you
think it binds our societies together
we're trying to spend their days due to
be cooking and cleaning while their
husbands go to work eston Williams is a
25 year old Trad wife has amassed
hundreds of thousands of followers by
showing off her traged wife life online
if you can give up a job to be the
perfect wife so is she and others like a
saving Society we're always selling out
The Sisterhood well join me now is
traditional wife and influencer Esther
Williams and in the studio I'm a
socialist and author Grace Blakely and
YouTuber Pearl Davis this might be the
best lineup in the history of Television
for a a debate of this nature so I'm
very excited all right Ashley Williams
let's start with you is the the Trad
wife sell it to me why do you think we
should all go back to having Trad wives
in marriages
um well I believe that well I actually
don't believe that everyone should be a
traditional wife I think that it is a
choice and I think it's a lovely choice
if a woman wants to Simply Be a wife and
a mother and that's enough for her and I
it's it's a simple way of living with
traditional gender roles
um it's balanced and we don't have to do
it all as women I think we've proven
that um
it's possible but at what cost right
right and and in terms of what being a
Trad wife involves what do you think it
means to be a tread wife
well to adhere to traditional gender
roles so what I mean by that is the
husband he is the provider of the home
he goes out he works and he he knows how
to protect his family if need be and the
wife she's the Homemaker she does the
cooking she does the cleaning and she
takes care of the home and children if
there are any and
um herself of course so that's it's
adhering to traditional gender roles
okay grace I'm sure you thoroughly agree
with this
said about the
shoes obviously I completed
as well I think
is critique of traditional gender roles
and gender ideology isn't that some
people like to stay at home and others
don't it's that you shouldn't be bound
to pursue a certain life based on the
sex that you were born into at Birth the
one issue I do have is I know actually
um someone a friend of mine whose sister
got involved in the Trad wife movement
in the U.S basically and she was quite
young she got married to someone who was
like this is what we're doing you're
going to be a Trad wife and basically
came to regret it um she felt like she's
been controlled like her life became
very small and she couldn't get out she
couldn't escape because you know she'd
lost all her friends and and this has
become basically her entire life and it
concerns me that sometimes we see this
narrative on social media that women
have to be a certain way in order to get
her husband and so you have to be this
like particular model of femininity for
people to love you and I think that's
really sad because I don't think anyone
should have to shave off any parts of
themselves to be loved or to you know
find a husband or you know anything like
that all right Paul what do you think
um I think it's I think it's a good that
we're seeing a return to traditionalism
yeah I think it's a good thing
how I don't know how is the feminist
movement of the last few decades how has
it gone for you and when you look at it
and see how women have progressed do you
think it's been largely a Force for good
or do you think as the Trad wise do that
perhaps we've lost that sense of gender
rules one of a bit of race which
actually worked very well I mean I mean
we've seen families disappear
you know um I saw a study the other day
that said only 25 of I mean this is an
American Staff in American household to
a family so
um I guess there's positives and there's
negatives but it's like at what cost you
know well like 85 um 150 years ago the
average woman at seven kids 85 percent
of people were married I mean you know
mortality and women died very young and
you know I mean women were more
depressed than ever before we're on
antidepressants um
women over the age of 45 are the least
happy demographic there are a lot of the
issue the issue that's reasons for that
and the issue you have is women like
Emily Ratajkowski you know marriage
again I've said this before marriage
isn't marriage anymore the average
marriage is seven years we have things
like no fault divorce leave if you're
unhappy so what does that mean marriage
isn't marriage anymore because there are
so many marriages over the course of
history where people have been very
unhappy either the man or the woman has
been very unhappy and they've been
forced basically to stay in a marriage
it could have been an abusive marriage
and this is the problem we have with
women like women men tend to be better
people than us yeah they really do they
tend to no no they they tend to do the
right things
there's a reason we have phrases like a
man of his word right yeah
men will actually stick things out women
when tickets are we just leave and you
prove that you're putting my point what
was your first answer my happiness right
of course
the family doesn't work when it's about
you it's supposed to be about your kids
well and that's the pro that's the
problem everyone
do you think am I allowed to do cool
okay look I think relationships are
about balance they're about compromise
they're about knowing understanding
yourself learning to you know no
understand another person eventually
potentially if you want to bring
children into the world and teaching
them how to do that as well teaching
them to balance a sense of their own
identity with the love that they have
for for another person and you know for
example I know um an older woman
actually is friend of our family who um
got divorced about 60. she had you know
this lovely family they were together
since they were 18 and she said I got to
a point after I'd stopped being a mother
and you know I was just kind of getting
on I realized I'd lost my sense of who I
was and I didn't really feel like I knew
who I was anymore because I'd always
just been a wife and a mother and I
wanted to go out and explore that and I
think
what is traditionalism
um I don't know what you think I would
say a modern mentality is me before the
family I would say traditional
traditionalism is the family before me
especially in women and so and so and so
what I actually it's interesting you
said 60 year olds because you know I've
interviewed 600 700 people roughly in
the past year and a half I've done
hundreds of shows interviewing people
about relationships and what I find is
the 60 year olds tend to
a lot of those women LED their daughters
astray you know there's a reason we're
in this mess right a lot of those women
had the wrong mentality when it came to
marriage and had exactly the mentality
that you're talking about which
prioritize balancing one's own sense of
identity with compromise and
relationships myself before the marriage
but that's again and it's really
unfortunate because I would say the
women of Our Generation really are are
suffering because of the advice of the
women of the past that's an interesting
point here right which is that we do
live in a very individualistic society
and we're all told actually I think a
lot of the time in our relationships as
well you have to be a certain way if you
want to receive love you have to abide
by these uh these Norms you have to be a
certain level of attractiveness you have
to earn a certain amount of money it's
all about you and that's not what love
is yeah all right listen it's actually
been very interesting this into this let
me bringing back in Estes in terms of
trying values Like My Wife puts the bins
out for example right I don't I've never
asked her to she's just adopted that
role in our house so I never put the
bins out I don't know if I should feel
ashamed of myself I do other stuff but I
don't put the bins out as a trans wife
do you put your bins out is that part of
the gender rule of the 50s is that what
used to happen or does the man supposed
to do that I mean how do these rules
work in reality
to be honest it it has nothing it I
don't want to say nothing it doesn't
necessarily have anything to do with the
50s and the 60s
um especially in our household I I
enjoyed the aesthetic and I think that's
where people get a little mixed up with
my channel but um I well to answer your
question actually I I don't put the
charger bins out my husband does that
but
I think we we have this um this thing in
our household where he does most of the
outdoor work I do all the indoor work of
course he works and provides and I'm the
Homemaker that's what works for us but
in relationships in relation to what
right in relation to what Pearl said
it's it's part of a sense of being
dutiful and having no problem actually
with being dutiful in a marriage
uh yes I believe that traditionalism can
it is putting um your family before
yourself and I think it it is
um
it is having those Traditional Values
that were once definitely more in place
in God family and love and we live in a
very selfish Society now you know you
see self-love printed everywhere right
and
um women I speaking of divorce and
marriage women are leaving marriage far
more easy easilier than uh men and they
are doing it because they think there's
something better out there for them that
the grass is greener on the other side
and they're finding out that is wrong
and they're going through divorce after
divorce and um you know marriage is a
bond and it's a sacred Bond where two
become one under God and that's
beautiful and you have to protect that
at all costs and and I think part of
that is putting your partner's needs
before your own every single day and I
try and do my best and I think of my
husband as much as I can and what will
please him and make him happy I'd love
to the sound of this sorry I mean I mean
obviously I don't I wouldn't dare to
express an opinion but you know a lovely
way to think about relationships if it's
reciprocal um you're talking about about
God and family and
traditionally finish my sentence
women were supposed to you know
recognize their place and learn not to
speak over other people
um no so look I think it's reciprocated
you talked there about about religion
about Christianity and about self-love
you know the the like most important
commandment there's two most important
moments love your neighbor as yourself
so that requires a foundation of
self-love and respect for oneself and
knowledge of One's Own identity and what
one wants to be able to receive and give
the love that you're going to have in a
solid and healthy relationship I think
it has to be music you're not looking
forward to getting you all back uh in
about 10 years time to see if either of
you two are married and have stayed
married and to see particularly as if
you're still married and still happily
married and still feel exactly the same
way you do today about what marriage
should be that would be a really
interesting thing how happy we are in
general with our lives and all the other
many Rich aspects of our relationships
and our careers and all of these things
yep uh great debate thank you very much
ladies nice to see you all and so next
I'll speak a bit of a gear change this
to the ex-wife of or serial killer Carl
Carlson who murdered his previous
partner and his son 17 years apart for
the insurance mode
you'll secure lots of other things and
torch cars I spoke to him for a brand
new series on Fox Nation and tonight I
talked to the woman who helped put him
behind bars plus his second wife
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s and we've got a huge big show coming
up we certainly have GB news suspends
two presenters over misogynistic
comments about a journalist a judge
rules Donald Trump lied for years about
how rich he really is and we're asking
if it's time to slim down the monarchy
that's all coming up at nine
[Music]
it's the horrific story now of two
murders intricately linked Carl Carlson
murdered his wife Christina and Son Levi
17 years apart for one sole purpose it
turned out insurance money both deaths
were initially deemed accidents but
Carl's lies eventually caught up on him
and the 62 year old faces the rest of
his life Behind Bars well I sat down
with him for a pretty harrowing hour for
a new series that's now on Fox Nation in
America called the killer interview with
Piers Morgan I asked Carl Carlson but it
was just bad luck as he claims or if he
was indeed a ruthless murderer
62 year old convicted murderer Carl
Carlson wants you to believe he's guilty
of nothing more than having bad luck his
horses died his wife died his son died
my stepson there had been a fire at my
sister's house and my sister did not
make it out but his Castle's Misfortune
a cover for something more Sinister and
Carl Carlson needs money people have
accidents Levi had a life insurance
policy over seven hundred thousand
dollars I've been given one hour at
Carlson coming soon who says he was
forced into a confession he doesn't stab
them he doesn't shoot him he creates a
hazardous situation and then sits back
and lets his situation kill them are you
the world's unluckiest human being or
are you a ruthless killer
well I know my view a ruthless killer
tonight I'm joined by the ex-wife of
gold cast and Cindy best who became
suspicious of her husband included with
the police to get a confession from him
and the true crime author of Levi's eyes
which is out today Aphrodite Joseph
welcome to both of you thank you for
joining the program Aphrodite let me
start with you first just to paint a
picture you've written a gripping book
about this Levi's eyes a son's Deadly
Secret a father's cruel betrayal the
more I got into the weeds of Karl Castle
Story the more shocking it became it
wasn't just his first wife and his son
that he effectively uh Let Die for
insurance money it was a bunch of horses
in a barn that he kept it was cars that
were being torched you he was claiming
for almost everything he could think of
and then that would either be torched or
killed or whatever it may be I mean a
truly terrifying individual
yes and in fact Pierce first of all I
loved how you went after him and made
him squirm in that seat
um I I have a different experience with
him in that I was able to talk to this
killer for two years plus five days a
week I'm he was calling during the trial
before the trial after the trial it's
unprecedented I've been doing true crime
books now for 30 years and I've never
had that kind of access to a killer
um what that did for me is to make me
understand uh the mentality of this
person and get into his mind more than
I've ever in any killer I've ever
written about or interviewed and um what
what I realize is this man actually
believes that you're going to forget
what happened in the past right so in
other words his wife Christina died in
the fire that's over
you know um so the difference is I
couldn't confront him because I kept
pulling out jewels that are insane out
of this psychopath's mouth okay and it
just it led me to understand something
very important here which is the
connection is not just money the
connection is not just what Levi saw
which we believe he saw his father ready
to kill all of them in the house in that
fire yeah but it's also a very strange
relationship Pierce between Levi and his
father because what made Levi get under
that truck on the same day that he
signed a will over to his father leaving
all his Earthly possessions there well
that's he knew his father was a killer
yeah I mean there is a baffling uh part
of this let me bringing Cindy here
because Cindy you began to have
suspicions didn't you about about Carl
and you actually cooperated uh with the
police in trying to expose him
um you know when I sat with him I've got
to say I just realized quite quickly
that he was a very very sophisticated
liar that he would look me straight in
the eye and tell point-blank lies when
you look back now on your time with him
obviously you were married to him do you
now think the same about him he just
lied the whole time
uh yeah uh during our marriage I knew
that you know that's the one thing that
I knew most about him that he was a liar
you know we had many fights about it he
just but then there would be times where
he'd put just enough truth into
something to make me question myself
you know is that true or it was just uh
bizarre you know but that feeling that
feeling Cindy when you discover that his
first wife didn't die accidentally in
this house fire that it was deliberate
and that he got 215 000 from an
insurance policy as a result and then
his son 17 years later he gets a 700 000
pound insurance payout on that at that
point are you fearing for your life and
the life of all the other kids in this
scenario what are you thinking
yeah well first
um I started suspecting about Levi
um you know I knew about Christina but I
didn't know all the details and
everything but things just really didn't
start adding up with Carl and the things
that he was telling me and kind of
changing his story a little bit and
that's when I really
you know I call them pan attacks panic
attacks that I would have where you know
I'd just be in a panic thinking oh my
God he did it but then there would be
times or you know I would think
um I would justify why he couldn't have
done it you know there were so many
reasons you know law enforcement said it
was an accident
um you know they the coroner put the
time of death at you know this time we
weren't home at that time so you know it
was uh
it was a process getting to the point
where I you know
could definitely you know feared that
this was true a d fear now looking back
on it if he hadn't been caught and put
in prison now for the rest of his life
uh that he may have done something to
you
yeah I I feared
um more for my granddaughters
um that you know he would probably have
a better opportunity
um
to do something to them yes I feared for
my own life and
it
it was just a bizarre thing to live
through yeah you know absolutely yeah
horrific I can't imagine anything worse
and awful for you uh Aphrodite you know
obviously there's a lot of killers a lot
of serial killers Psychopaths all sorts
of different kind of killers many of
them uh do commit crimes of passion in
many cases we know most murders are
crimes of passion there was something
particularly evil about Carl Carlson for
me because it was the way that he
planned all these things so meticulously
and it was all for financial gain that
he just wanted to get money and he
didn't care if he killed a wife or a
child or you know anything close to him
I mean really scary guy
well and and as Cindy pointed out and
you were asking this is particular to
the the story he took out life insurance
policies on his two granddaughters when
I wrote this I had no idea that someone
could even do that without the
granddaughter's present he did that he
had 250 000 on each child and on Cindy
through death benefits on an annuity he
took out he had 1.2 million dollars
right that he would collect so the idea
would be he would have killed Cindy and
one of his granddaughters therefore
collecting a million and a half dollars
that was his next move yes so talking
about planning you have to understand he
finessed Cindy into signing those
documents in which she was in essence
signing her life away and her
granddaughter's lives away because he
had so much paperwork going back and
forth she was Bamboozled and I mean
even as you're talking about it's
bringing it it's bringing a chill to my
Spine Cindy I just want to say to you
you know I flew over I interviewed Carl
at length as you know uh and it's airing
now people can watch this on on Fox
Nation but I just want to say to you
just you know how sorry I am that you
went through this and how much I
appreciate you
coming on the program to talk about what
must be you know most people who don't
know you it's just a horrible crime
story for you this was your life and it
could have cost you your life and I just
want to say I'm really sorry for what
you went through
oh thanks for saying that pierce yeah
um it you know I'm coming out the other
side and you know trying to do good for
other people and yeah you know it's it
you know I know Cindy we've got to leave
it there I wish you all the very best I
really do I mean that and Aphrodite
thank you for coming on uh the book's
called Levi's eyes the son's Deadly
Secret a father's cruel betrayal it's a
gripping book about an extraordinary
story and I appreciate it and for
viewers in America you can watch all
eight of my crime documentaries on Fox
Nation they're on there now and they'll
be coming to other territories I'm sure
before too long that's it for tonight
people don't send it good night
[Music]
thank you
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think it's only one for one king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about left he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
way TK team that would make her a better
princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time I obviously wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
[Music]